bonjour je m'appelle alexandre physique
et je suis stagiaire postdoctoral au
centre de recherche du chum je travaille
en neurobiologie de l'obésité bref je
m'affaire à essayer de comprendre
l'obésité et comprendre comment le
cerveau peut contrôler par exemple
l'appétit
on s'est attardé à essayer de comprendre
le rôle d'un enzyme qu'on appelle à bh
des six qui est capable de ralentir
l'activité de certaines régions du
cerveau
on s'est particulièrement attardé à
l'hypothalamus une région qui agir en
tant que thermostat énergétique pour le
corps donc est capable de réguler
l'appétit et la dépense d'énergie
est ce que c'est possible qu'à travers
soi des défauts génétiques ou des
défauts qui serait acquis à travers
d'une mauvaise alimentation qui
habillage des six pour avoir une perte
de fonctionnalité
il pourrait donc une nuire à la perte de
poids ou favoriser le guen points c'est
quelque chose qui est très intéressant
présentement qui le centre de nos
recherches et qui pourrait
éventuellement déboucher sur des avenues
thérapeutiques